So let's take a look at how to
add a polyline to your map.
Now a polyline is defined with the
polylineoptions() .geodesic(true) and
then you simple add a LatLng to that.
You can stack these adds into
a single column as you can see here.
Where my PolylineOptions.geodesic(true),
I just add LatLng, add another one,
add another one and add another one.
This makes your code a little
bit easier to read and
a little bit easier to manage.
See if you can edit
the hockey application so
instead of pins for each rinks you
have end points and a line segment.
And as a result you would have a shape
outlining where all the rinks are and
the area contained within.